c'est dans cette pièce délabré du
pavillon du verger que se cachent les
médaillons un décor date et 2770
dissimulée sous plusieurs couches de
peinture qui en cache la finesse le but
de la restauration c'est d'abord de
préserver le monument qui se trouve très
dégradé et le décor en danger puisque il
ya beaucoup d'infiltrations donc ce
décor qui est essentiellement en plâtre
est complètement solidaire du monument
le travail des restaurateurs de monsieur
madame données donati va d'abord
consister à dégager les multiples
couches de repeint pour retrouver les
couleurs d'origine donc ils ont fait
d'eux des sondages situé à quelques
mètres seulement du palais du roi de
rome le pavillon du verger est acheté en
1727 par le comte de toulouse
il appartient à la ville de rambouillet
depuis 1989
on est en train de finaliser le projet
de restauration les appels d'offres aux
entreprises devrait être lancé d'ici
l'été pour un début de chantier à
l'automne 2010 huit ans donc c'est un
projet en fait qui va durer à peu près
un an et demi pour imaginer une
inauguration en 2020 d'un montant de 600
mille euros le chantier sera
subventionné à hauteur de 70% par la
drac notamment il se visitera sur
réservation